- As the war rages over here in Gaza,
mediation efforts are being led by Qatar,
a tiny peninsula on the
Persian Gulf 1,100 miles away.
The country has used its
close ties with both Hamas
and the West to negotiate the
release of hostages from Gaza
and get others out through the
border crossing with Egypt.
It's just the latest example
of Qatar's important
role on the world stage,
from helping the US evacuate thousands
of people from Afghanistan to
brokering a prisoner swap deal
between the US and Iran.
Here's how Qatar became
such an important player
in global diplomacy.
Qatar's location and economic clout
make it strategically important
to a lot of different countries.
It shares its only land
border with Saudi Arabia,
a major power in the Middle East,
and it shares the world's
largest natural gas field
right here with Iran, Saudi's
biggest regional rival.
Exports of liquified natural
gas have made Qatar one
of the wealthiest countries in the world,
boosting its influence
in this volatile region.
This has made Qatar a critical
energy partner for a lot
of countries, especially those in Europe
because the continent has
been reducing its reliance
on Russian oil and gas.
Qatar is also important
to the United States,
and right here is the
biggest US military base
in the Middle East.
It's been a launching pad for
operations in Afghanistan,
Iraq, and Syria.
Last year, the US made
Qatar a major non-NATO ally.
Qatar has also made itself
influential in the broader region
through Al Jazeera,
the largest news media
network in the Middle East,
but it has been criticized
in both the Arab world
and the West for its sometimes
controversial coverage
of uprisings, wars and other conflicts.
For example, the network
broadcast video messages
from Osama bin Laden after 9/11.
Nevertheless, Qatar prides
itself on being a meeting place
for diverse viewpoints,
which was on full display
when the country hosted
the World Cup last year,
and its ambassador to the US
recently wrote an opinion piece
in The Wall Street Journal,
claiming that "Qatar is the
Mid-East's honest broker."
In the 1980s and '90s
the country's leaders developed
relationships with Iran,
as well as regional groups like Hamas
in the Palestinian territories
and the Muslim Brotherhood in Egypt,
groups that are considered
terrorist organizations
in some parts of the world.
It also fostered ties
with the Afghan Taliban.
In 2013, the Taliban opened
a political office in Qatar
with support from the US
and Afghan governments.
Years of negotiations in
Doha led to a deal in 2020
for US troops to withdraw
from Afghanistan,
ending America's longest war.
(people clapping)
But the agreement didn't
bring peace to the country.
The Taliban never reached
a power sharing agreement
with the Afghan government,
and it seized control of Kabul in 2021.
Qatar helped to evacuate US
citizens in the aftermath,
and it is now Washington's
diplomatic representative
in the country.
Hamas also opened a political
office in Qatar in 2012
after a request by the
Obama administration
to establish indirect
lines of communication,
and Qatar has provided financial aid
to Palestinians in Gaza,
which is run by Hamas.
That has led to accusations
of funding terrorism,
which Qatar denies.
Qatar's complex web of relationships
has caused friction with its neighbors.
In 2017, it was blockaded
by Saudi Arabia, the UAE,
Bahrain and Egypt.
They accused Doha of meddling
in their domestic affairs,
supporting extremist groups,
and being too close to
regional rival Iran.
The four countries
issued a list of demands,
including shutting down Al Jazeera
and reducing ties with Tehran.
Even though Qatar didn't make concessions,
the blockade ended in January of 2021,
and the terms of the deal
haven't been made public.
Although the country's
reestablished relations,
some analysts say that the root causes
of that diplomatic crisis
haven't been resolved.
Today, Qatar's diplomatic relationships
are in the spotlight once again
with the country negotiating the release
of hostages taken from
Israel into Gaza by Hamas.
(bomb exploding)
But Qatar said that without a
pause in the fighting in Gaza,
its mediators won't be
able to do their work.
- It's a very, very difficult negotiation
that we've been dealing with.
I always say that one of
the most difficult mediation
is difficult between two parties
that have zero confidence in each other.
- Israeli officials have said
that Qatar's efforts are
crucial at this time,
but so far, only a few
hostages have been released.
And when the crisis is over,
many of Qatar's partners want it
to expel Hamas leaders from the country,
that includes more than
100 members of Congress
who signed a letter to President Biden.
Qatar said that the political office
of Hamas will remain open as long
as it can be used toward peace.
Some diplomats worry
that those Hamas leaders
could move somewhere
more hostile to the West,
like Iran or Syria.
That could make any
communication between Hamas,
Israel and the West even more complicated
in situations like the one
that is currently unfolding
in the Middle East.
(pensive music)